the FBI opened his civil rights
investigation to the deadly shooting at
a church in Nashville over the weekend
the suspect is 25 year-old Emanuel
Khadijah Simpson he is in police custody
today after shooting himself yesterday
by accident Nashville police say that
Samson killed one woman in the parking
lot and wounded seven other people
Samson is a legal us resident who came
here from Sudan back in 1996 church
members are now praising an usher who
confronted the gunman Errol Barnett is
outside the Burnet Chapel Church of
Christ rather in Nashville with the
latest on this story
Errol good morning good morning
authorities are still searching for a
motive which drove Samson to attack
churchgoers at this otherwise peaceful
house of worship that witnesses say he
attended in the past they also say the
ordeal began just before 11:15 Sunday
morning as church services were being
let out you can only imagine the kind of
horror that unfolded inside of this
church
police say Samson drove this blue SUV up
to the church left the engine running
and got out with two pistols his face
partially covered with a mask they say
he then shot and killed Melanie Smith a
39 year old mother of two she was a
caring woman who loved God according to
her daughter Brianna everybody's looking
for why why why there's no understanding
evil there's no understanding hate
Sampson allegedly then entered the
church and walked down the aisle of the
main sanctuary shooting as he moved he
hit and wounded six people including the
church pastor before he was confronted
by 22 year old uh sure Caleb Engle
police say Sampson pistol-whipped angle
but then accidentally shot himself
during the scuffle and fell to the
ground this guy came I'm fighting with
him I'm chuckling dad this witness who
late attended to a pastor's wounds says
Engle jumped in as Sampson continued to
fire his weapon he was shooting and then
he sang in the pulpit he starts shooting
more injured from his struggle with
Samson
authorities say angle went outside to
his car to get his own registered gun
then went back into the church to stand
guard over the wounded shooter until
police arrived
mr. Engle saved countless lives
today he is at the end of the day the
hero in this because we think this could
have been much worse in terms of death
Samson has been charged with one count
of murder with additional charges
pending as for the man who tackled the
gunman he issued a statement saying he
actually doesn't want to be labeled a
hero he says that label should be
reserved for the police the first
responders and the doctors who have
helped and are helping everyone involved
Charlie thanks Errol